[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video ich
sitze hier in einem wunderschönen auto
in erics wunderschönem auto das hat der
brandneue gestern abgeholt freust du
dich ich freue mich
und wie haben das zum anlass genommen
dass wir heute einen tag lang nur im
auto essen das heißt wir fahren in
verschiedenen dreyfus holen uns was
zuerst ein paar sachen die man
vielleicht noch nicht kennt und was
viele von euch hier nicht unbedingt aus
düsseldorf nicht kennen ist der einzige
starbucks drei den es in deutschland
gibt und durch den fahren wir jetzt
habt ihr doch mal schauen was die fans
haben ja ich würde sagen schau erst mal
ein bisschen auf die felgen
wir haben hier sechs kuchenstücke deiner
wahl
1419 schnecke und grande café latte dass
ich mich schon eher 49 19 wir müssen
erst mal die karte studieren
eine zimtschnecken noch ein dritter
bacon and eggs berge bittet würde den
pumpkin grünkohl brutkästen in gran
david erste bestellung ist raus da hört
man leute das ist schon echt kraft wenn
man kennt was halt gar nicht so stark
klug aber wir sind eigentlich hätte den
matsch erholen boden 1 ist doch pumpkins
beißen ich habe das perfekte verträgen
codeprofiler ich sowieso das ding ist ja
ich habe ja meine kaffeemaschinen mache
ja sehr gerne guten kaffee war so kalt
und so das mache ich halt nicht selbst
das hat wenn ich außer haus was hole
dann gerne das eigentlich war das video
keinen sinn in einem ganz neuen auto ein
tag zu essen halten bis das konkret
ruft sie wir verlassen in drive thru
ganze auto voll mit essen wir suchen uns
jetzt mal entspannten ort um das ganze
zu snacken und dann können wir
diese in der in der business class cnooc
ich fühle mich wie so ein richtiger
amiwiese dreyfus starbucks geholt sitzt
hier in meinem tesla okay das ist auch
ein getränk so dass das ist auch
amerikanisch die es nur sein kann gehen
am rhein da oben so richtig dicke sahne
obendrauf unten drin haben die
klassischen koobloo kaffee also wer es
nicht kennt das ist einfach so wie
kalter kaffee halten also nicht süß
nicht irgendwas aber diese kurse trieben
hier um diesen kasten war das
unfreiwillig sehr bekannt das ist cool
ist das lecker was es trotzdem wert aber
ich bin echt gespannt ob kinect
beckenbauer r klebt so zusammen mit käse
personen hungrig aber auch so bock auf
dieses mittel essen heute ob dieses
junkfood dass sie mehr abschreiben denn
werde
ich verwerfe hat wenig fastfood
charakter und bagels 1 premium kaffee
ging im kleinen café essen leisten berge
aber der schmeckt nach fastfood und der
geschmack von fast um das fasten mit
einem macht manchmal will man das heute
ist bei mir so ein tag also für fast
food für drive thru
top-version den official money weit
gehen dass ich dir zu deinem großen tag
so saftig das erlebst du oder bacon so
drei von zehn ja aber der käse und das
innere dieses konnte diese konsistenz
die man im mund hat das hört sich
wahrscheinlich übels täglich angeraten
mit frühem und da ist das wichtig aber
das zu untermalen das fühlst du auch
wenn ich sage die tatsache dass der
bacon drei von zehn ist macht ihn zu
einer sieben von zehn es genau das was
du so willst also fast food reihenhaus
so dass er nicht so aus lockt und so und
das ist alles einfach so ein bisschen
anders ich halte das null auf dem schirm
das ist das wie und das ist so geil ist
mir wusste ich auch nicht ich hätte
gedacht dass sie so auch so echte herr
für wave dann gehen bei solchen dingen
auch merck schon leute heute wird auf
jeden fall ein sehr lustiger tag ich
hoffe ihr seht es uns nach dass wir uns
auch mal eine pause tag hätten
so ernst so am reifen
es gibt ja also viele leute setzten sich
mit tesla auseinander so aber es ist
einfach so lachen kann man dass man so
selbst boombox
wird es nochmal diese megafon funktion
also hier kommt die mucke raus und eric
testet jetzt megafon
eric gehört dir dass leute nichts weil
wir sind wieder in heßler gehört auch
die vögel zwitschern ihr seht vielleicht
auch die sonne ist wieder da und mit der
sonne ist auch unser appetit ein wenig
zurück gekehrt aber ich sage euch
ehrlich unser nächster stopp vielleicht
hat man schon gesehen es burger king
james auf jeden fall ein paar von diesen
kleinen based optionen rein können mit
ein paar meine ich eine weil er wirklich
kann nicht mehr das war zu krank dieses
frühstück hat mir so schwer im bauch
gelegen hat jemand erfahrung ich habe
schon wieder angst jährlich weil die
vorfreude dass es ein bisschen dadurch
geschmälert wie es mir gerade nach dem
fünfstündigen dann sage ich heute ganz
ehrlich das ist aber das ist so geil aus
gerade mit dem dach des bmw fehlt dann
kann die sonne so sehen aber auch uns
wir hätten gerne einmal einen whopper
plant base menü zu noch viele pläne base
nugget und süß sauer sagt ehrlich so
sehr wie ich gelitten habe so sehr
steigt mir die geruch gerade hier von
wie kane die nase die ganzen lernen sind
ja alle wie parfümiert so und man hat
schon wieder 15 minuten wo ich esse
werde ich wieder spaß haben danach
da mir das essen so ruhigen platz dann
wird man wieder im auto gegessen ist im
auto essen da habe ich echt spaß dann
halt eigentlich nur mit zusätzlichem
haben gleich einen wichtigen einkauf vor
uns und zwar so alles was wir in der
neuen küche brauchen werden deshalb
hoffe ich dass mich das stärkt gehe vom
gegenteil aus
auf jeden fall zu ihrem großen partie
drauf ich habe wirklich selten bisher
dieser plan fest option bolt aber ich
weiß dass vieles tun ich freue mich
jetzt auch auf den geschmack
ich musste sagen ist halt schon das
mekka geil ferne sind kann es nicht
anders sagen so ist es und es schmeckt
aber nach der prüfung ich habe jetzt so
genüge gesagt aber das war wirklich
krasse tja so am arsch nachricht wird
auf jeden fall ein kleiner bürger das
plant base verdiene schmeckt man aber
raus also es ist nicht so beim lang
schicken oder sagen wir vieles eins zu
eins jetzt also ein bisschen so man
merkt an der textur dass wir so eine
masse ist seine bisherige masse
geschmack ist trotzdem sehr sehr lecker
gehen wir mal die place nuggets
[Musik]
textur eric das richtig füttern aber ich
muss sagen man schmeckt schon dass es
keinen schicken ist bei dem finde ich
jetzt stehe jetzt ersatzprodukte
funktionieren natürlich am besten wenn
sie andere sachen sind die dich noch
zusätzlich erinnern für die kanadische
teile davon coca cola coca cola
coca cola
hoffe ich kann mich jetzt konzentrieren
weil wir brauchen eigentlich alles für
die küche wir brauchen reiben wir
brauchen kleine schalen brauchen
kochgeschirr wir brauchen zahlen viele
das ist so krass weil ich bin mir sicher
das ist lange nicht alles wir werden
noch so oft sagen war das brauchen wir
auch noch aber so ist das alter und die
beste küche auf ganz youtube einrichten
das team für mich aber ich weiß nicht ob
sie zu anstrengend weil ich da noch gut
gegangen weil wir einfach so viel schlaf
ausgewählten ich glaube 500 506 so sagt
550 muss raten ich habe nämlich nicht
mitgeholfen muss auszusuchen
was ist das kostet 4 78
was aber was war so teuer
900 euro aber das traurige ist dass es
noch lange nicht alles ist aber ihr
wisst vielleicht schon was die küche
gekostet habe ich habe es einmal
erzählte podcast dass man alles dem
braten nicht mehr
erste mahlzeit des tages
ein bisschen los weiß warum facebook
habe den arm mit zum knall zu wählen ich
möchte nämlich zutiefst erstmal und dann
möchte ich mir hot wings bestellen und
ich würde ihm sagen die sollen wir die
heißeste sauce geben die sie haben und
dann die ich mit bauchschmerzen ohne
energie einfach schlafen und dann war
ich morgen für auf und es wahrscheinlich
nichts außer gemüse für einen tag
hallo ich hätte gerne sechs hot wings
mit pommes oder seo und die schärfste
soße die sie haben ich
wusste nicht dass diese soße gibt hat
for you klingt schon ein bisschen
gruselig
es klingt so als würde ich vielleicht
mein call bereuen
der tisch wird wieder gedeckt
als ich mich fühle auch diese dem drops
der diesen
[Musik]
nicht so gut sagt mir das jetzt bitte
nicht weil für mich sehen sie gerade
auch nicht besonders für hot four jusos
hast du die gesehen es klingt schon ein
bisschen gruselig
schon heiß gehen einfach reinigen die
masse
ja wir haben es ich schaffe das schon
geil chicken wings paniert und frittiert
für uns überraschend lecker nun ja ich
probiere mal die schärfsten soße der
welt
einmal so auf machen hier dann siehst du
so bewusst der kleinere knochen und
zudem so brauns das ist nicht unbedingt
so die feinste englische art das sucht
man dazu sagen dann einen iso russe und
jetzt kommt also das bisschen ruiniert
aber
[Musik]
man muss dazu sagen es ist sehr
effizient detailliert was soll ich sagen
wir haben einen tag lang nur im auto
gegessen es
war es war schon lecker geht einmal aber
nicht gut vertraut dem lustig
insbesondere so ein neues video
abzufilmen aber wie gesagt ab morgen
einen tag lang nur gemüse essen keine
sorge komme ich auf youtube das wollte
wahrscheinlich auch nicht sehen wir
sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
macht es gut und danke dass wir in einem
neuen auto ich danke allen
was ist das ja dass ein video über den
kopf und was ist da eingeblendet eine
empfehlung für den zuschauer individuell
so ist ist hast dann seid doch so nett
und guckt ihr weniges mal an